foreign
[Music]
around the corner this National bats
appreciation week and yes there is such
a thing in a small Texas town they've
taken appreciation to a whole new level
coming to the rescue of more than a
million mammals who've made the
community their home cbs's Janet
shamlian is there
it doesn't look like a point of interest
but this crumbling Warehouse with
shattered windows and sprouting trees
becomes one as the sun sets in
Huntsville Texas it's still way
underrated as far as tourist
destinations thing things to check out
Tommy Hoke still remembers his first
time I was blown away I didn't know what
to expect and then when I saw it I just
I couldn't believe watching it was
amazing
it's a common reaction to the evening
show by more than a million Mexican
retailed bats
emerging on mass for nighttime
nourishment from a place they've called
home for years but technically isn't
theirs
the bats are a population the Texas
State Penitentiary has long wanted gone
it owns the building effectively the
bat's landlord and has tried to get them
to move into these bat houses just 50
feet away there have been no takers
they're in direct sunlight for nearly
all day and they're painted black so
they're essentially what some people
call bat ovens earlier this year word
came the building would be torn down for
safety reasons the fate of the bats
uncertain I was looking at that building
knowing what was imminent
it really just convicted to me that if I
don't do something now if I don't say
something at least make some sort of an
effort it's something that in hindsight
I will regret for the rest of my life
hoax started to save the Huntsville bats
Facebook page
thousands joined or made their own pleas
ant agreed to hit pause are you a bad
guy I wasn't but I am now you are yeah
city council member Russell Humphrey is
part of a group local leaders prison
reps and bad experts working to find the
colony a home they will move to the
Texas Department of Criminal Justice
tells CBS news we are taking additional
time to ensure community members and
Advocates are engaged in the discussion
when you heard that the prison was going
to stop demolishing the warehouse what
did you think I thought wow this is
amazing I can't believe because I had so
many people tell me
it's not going to happen we like what
you're doing we we think that's great
yeah we wish we could save it but it's
not going to happen for now the nightly
flights continue
the giant roadside statue of Texas
General Sam Houston is still
huntsville's most notable landmark
but the bats are gaining ground in its
gift store there's recognition of the
city's unofficial tourist attraction you
can buy that t-shirt that cookie cutter
even take home a stuffed bath I have
been out here probably since may I uh
probably 150 times with earlier sunsets
they're harder to see this time of year
especially if you're as blind as a well
you know it never gets old and a lot of
times it's so rewarding I'll hear little
kids voices and the excitement in there
in their voice kids here tonight yeah
yeah and it's great I love hearing that
children like Adelaide who got this for
you
um I picked it up myself at five already
a bat fan I love bats
and
I think they love me too the prison
baths for now granted a temporary stay
for CBS Saturday morning Janet shamley
Huntsville Texas
I could be a bad girl I really could
sure sure why not you got a good outfit
for it yeah yeah it looks good I like
this I like the stuffed bat the stuff
that was very nice yeah yeah now is what
you were saying about how much bats eat
every day
mosquitoes they eat their body weight in
mosquitoes every day they don't weigh a
lot so they can help the environment
that definitely Dana's had some great
back trivia this morning yeah thank you
Cindy
Cindy had great questions she looked it
up for me